hello everyone
i'm ryozo tsujimoto producer of the
monster hunter series thank you for
tuning in to today's capcom showcase
we're excited to bring you the latest
info on monster hunter rise sun break
which will finally be released at the
end of this month
to kick things off we've got a brand new
trailer to show you
let's take a look
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
wow
let's go for a ride
they're starting a fight
you look like you still got that fire
inside yo gal yes you do as well good
elton what do you say full steam ahead
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
first let me introduce a returning
locale
the jungle area that debuted in the
second generation of monster hunter
games is back in sun break
you'll notice that the jungle's
appearance changes over time it's a
nostalgic area that both veteran hunters
and new players are sure to enjoy and of
course we've updated the jungle with new
elements and endemic life specifically
for its return in sun break long time
fans can look forward to exploring the
devastated ruins around the coastal area
from the monster hunter frontier series
comes espinas
espinas means thorns in spanish
as the name implies thorny scales cover
its body
normally espinos enjoys a quiet life and
sleeps peacefully but when it senses
danger nearby it explodes into a violent
rampage even though it can seem docile
espionage has a two-faced nature that
can be extremely dangerous
the flagship monster of monster hunter 4
gore magala is back
gore magala is a sightless creature with
black scales and sensitive wing
membranes used to sense the presence of
prey
[Music]
as gourmagala's sensing ability
increases its two horns change form and
it enters the frenzy state
while in a frenzy state it gets so
powerful that the ground beneath begins
to break
and it uses its huge claws as an anchor
during powerful attacks
[Music]
in addition the trailer also shows the
daimyo hermitage and the pyro rock
nakadaki subspecies which adds explosive
elements makes its fiery debut there are
still more monsters that have yet to be
revealed so stay tuned for more sun
break announcements in the future
there's one more thing i want to share
with you all so please watch the
following video
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
a free demo for monster hunter rise sun
break is coming to both nintendo switch
and steam the demo will be available to
download as shown
in the jungle locale introduced today
you'll be able to take on astalos
the new switch skill swap system as well
as new silk bind attacks will be
available for play
we'll have a few tutorial quests
available for new players that will
teach you the basic mechanics and modes
after mastering the basics you'll be
ready to take on other monsters in the
demo to test your skills for veteran
hunters an advanced quest will also be
available where you can take on an extra
challenging version of sun breaks
flagship monster malzeno
the demo supports multiplayer for up to
four players and there's no limit to the
number of times you can attempt quests
get an early taste of sun break action
with this free demo you can download it
from the nintendo eshop and steam store
page
also we would like for you to keep two
things in mind when purchasing monster
hunter rise sunbreak
so you will be able to enjoy all the
added contents
following sun breaks release we plan to
release a number of free title updates
please enjoy this quick video preview of
what's on the way
[Music]
[Applause]
our first title update scheduled for
august 2022
we'll add lucent nargakuka
this monster will be a part of the first
free title update to come to sunbreak
post launch
in addition to the lucent nagakuga we're
also adding a new area the iconic
forlorn arena with future title updates
we plan on including additional monsters
variants and more
our title update release schedule is as
follows the second title update is
planned for a fall 2022 release the
third title update will come in winter
2022
and there's more to come in 2023
each title update will include
additional monsters and other elements
we hope you'll check them out
[Music]
monster hunter rise sun break will be
released worldwide on june 30th 2022.
[Music]
digital pre-orders for sun break are now
available on both nintendo switch and
steam
pre-orders will also receive a special
bonus palamute and palico layered armor
set
we're planning on keeping you updated
with more information soon
please visit the official website and
follow monster hunter social channels
for more info
that wraps up our news for monster
hunter rise sun
thanks for tuning in and enjoy the rest
of the capcom showcase